welcome back to 8701
so the name of this class is called
cardiomystic but what we're actually
going to do
is we're going to evaluate or learn how
to deal with spin information
in the calculation of our matrix
elements
so now what what is it what we're trying
to do so the first
problem we might have is that we have
polarized particles
so we have here again our example of
electron neuron scattering
and if you assume that the electron and
the neurons are polarized
you you will find as we discussed in the
previous lecture
that our matrix element is proportional
to
the joint vector of u1 times
some sort of gamma matrix times the
sphenoid and we probably have a
polarization vector as well included
here to give the polarization of the
photon involved in
in the um as a propagation good
now in order to now get a number for m
we actually have to be explicit
about um the wave function of the
external particles and you can do this
you can just write this down
however in experiments we are often
interested in the scattering of
unpolarized particles
um you know even if you have a way to
polarize a beam
your polarization is not going to be
perfect so in your calculation you might
want to
you know average or
thumb over the available spins of your
particle
so now how how are we going to do this
um so we're trying to calculate the spin
averaged amplitude why averaging
um we want to average over the
polarization of the incoming particles
again because we don't know what the
polarization states
are and we want to sum over the
polarization of all final state
particles
simply because you know each
polarization state is a possible outcome
of the interaction and we have to sum
over all possible outcomes good
um so how do we calculate the spin
average amplitude
so again we start from our matrix
element
where we have the joint vector some
gamma matrix and
our sphenoid um if we then calculate the
square
of this matrix we find this solution
here
great and now we're just doing a few
tricks um
so first of all we can write our joint
vector u1
equal to u dagger 1
gamma not and then just continue this
rewriting
until we find this part here the
solution which looks a little bit
simpler
where we have um now their joint matrix
instead of their joint
joint matrix given here so we want to
evaluate
what this a joint q1 gamma
u2 is times the joint u2 gamma
the joint u1 okay good so this was just
matrix
algebra and working with camera matrix
so far
now we're using this completion relation
um where i probably haven't told you yet
what this
um what this syntax here is
so gamma flash is equal to gamma mu
[Music]
and that's just the way to simplify
writing multiply the equation so if
if you use this so-called find slash
you can also rewrite the dirac equation
in a simple form
i del slash minus m
y equal to zero that's now our directive
remember there was a
um gamma mu uh
dnu here all right um that's just the
cycle mark and we have to
sum over all spin states uh or the spin
states of all
of all both particles now if we start
with summing over particle two
we can rewrite this here we use this
equation this
completely relation and just redefine
this q as equal to this part here
okay so now we have this equation here
which looks a little bit simpler because
we just have
our um incoming and outgoing spinos
for particle one given here
all right now we're looking at this part
of the equation now
and again we're just doing a little bit
of matrix
algebra here we find that this is equal
to uh qu1 u1
ii which is just simply summing over the
same indices
which is the same as building the trace
of this matrix
all right so if you just put all of
those together he finds that
calculating the sum of matrix elements
is similar to building the trace of a
matrix and then
our final results think even though this
one
[Music]
all right so summarizing this part
we have a matrix element and we saw that
the matrix elements of this form is
proportional to this form
and then when we try to calculate the
spin average matrix element squared
that's equal to the traces of the
particles involved using the completion
function there's an additional part one
additional factor one half here which
comes from the averaging over the
initial spins
so assuming exactly one of u1 and q2
corresponds to the initial to the
initial particles we find this factor
one half if both initial particles
are the same like in perineulation
then factor is one quarter and if
neither is
in the initial state then the factor is
one one
which you would have for a pair
production
okay good so now we simplified the
calculation of
our matrix elements putting the specific
spin states in there in the specific
polarization
um vectors towards the calculation of
traces of matrices so now we can look in
what does it mean so what is that
this is this is what carbonyl's trick
really is about
so summing over all spins reduces to
coming over mattresses if you have
anti-particles
the completeness relation reduces to
p slash minus m um
and then we can go ahead so all you need
to know now is how to do these traces
so first some general remarks and traces
if you have two matrices a and b
you want to calculate the trace of a
plus b
that's equal to the trace of a plus
trade of b
if you have a multiplicator here a
vector alpha you can just take this out
of the
of the calculation of the trace
um thus in those traces
two matrices commit communicate the
trace of a times b
is equal to the trace of b times a and
then you can use this in order to show
more complicated relations like this
okay
good um we have already started playing
around with the gamma matrices here are
a few more identities which might be of
use when you calculate
traces and you calculate matrix elements
overall the first one is this
g minou times g minou is equal to four
um the anti-community commutator
relation we already discussed and have
shown
in our one of our presentation and if
you have three matrices you can rewrite
them
as minus two times the metric
which is in the middle here okay
so i'm not going through this in much
detail here but i encourage you
to just follow those additional exercise
if you didn't have the opportunity yet
to play with those mattresses
and then you can use those those tricks
for example the anti-communic commutator
relation
to calculate the traces of
uh for example gamma mu which is four
times
g minus okay so what you see here is i
basically
used this anti-community commutator
relation
put it in here use this part here
this is basically one straight of one is
four so
we get gb mu times the trailer one
over four times four matrix is four and
so you get
the trace of gamma mu common is
okay and so on um later on um we haven't
discussed gamma 5 yet so much
gamma 5 is defined as i times gamma 0
comma 1 gamma 2 gamma 3.
you will see when we discuss the weak
interaction that there is a prominent
role for gamma 5 this
is very special common matrix and here
are just some
um pieces of information for traces for
number five the trace of comma 5 is
zero the j gamma five times
a different gamma matrix is zero and
that's also true for the products of
additional gamma matrices which you can
find when you
just try to calculate this relation
okay um one last piece of the
uh traces with gamma matrices is shown
here
um only with four or more gamma matrices
can you define
or find a non-zero trace involving gamma
matrices and here's one example
where you have the product of five or
four gamma matrices with gamma five
and that's equal in this case 4 times i
times
the total asymmetric tensor the total
asymmetry tender is defined as -1
for even permutations of those numbers
here
plus 1 for odd permutations and zero
if there's two indexes all right
again i'm not showing you this um
[Music]
in too much detail but i encourage you
to you know play around and you will be
asked in the homework in the next
homework
to play around with some of the
calculations